What's up guys!
We are Pongfinity
We have just hit 2 million subscribers
And just want to say a huge thank you
To all of you who have been watching and supporting our channel
Making videos wouldn't be possible with you
We are also excited to launch our new merch-line with Fanjoy
Along with this limited edition 2 million design
These shirts will be available only during
this month
So make sure to get yours now!
As for this video, we are going to be playing a stereotypes
match
So try to spot as many as you can!
Come on!
Which shirt should I put on today?
Hmm...
Yea, I think I'll go for this one!
I think it looks pretty good
Okay, so the racket then
Hmm...
I think I'll go for this one!
Good luck Otto! I'm sure...
You will have no chance
Oh, wait
Looking good!
Ah, thanks!
Are you ready now?
Just give me a second
Come on!
I'm ready!
I should have just kept with the underspin...
Thanks
Easy spot
Official rules say that you have to throw
the ball 16 cm up
Yeah, I did
Wait
I had my hand up
Come on!
So... lucky!
Well, it's not luck if I aim there
Actually! It didn't touch!
Yes, it did
No, it didn't!
It didn't
My point
No
Your point
Yes
My point
No
Yes
Okay, not then
Come on!
Chooo!
Thank you!
Come on!
I won a point!
Time out
Okay Otto, I'm ready!
A wet ball?
It's your sweat I think
That's how you want to play this game?
Mr excuses
Don't get mad
I'm not mad
I think it's your serve!
It is my serve
The racket is too good
And the bandana... I can't think with that!
Come on
Something weird on the surface...
What are you doing there?
Table is this way
Sorry!
Well, at least I won the point so I'm happy
Well done, Emil!
I bet you didn't see that coming!
No, I didn't
Don't give me there!
Thanks for the match!
Thanks!
Always a pleasure to play against the Sensei
Ah, thank you
So comment below all the stereotypes you found
in the match!
And guys remember
these 2M shirts
Are only available this November [2020]
So make sure to get one before time runs out!
Links are on the description!
Until next time!